let's talk about this story from a Daily
Mail Putin issues threat to U.S Vladimir
says we will deploy more than tanks and
warns we have friends on the American
continent apparently they're saying that
he's he's brought the nuclear football
with him the Russian version of it and
uh he's making a direct threat to the
United States over we're sending these
tanks our German tanks are being sent to
Ukraine basically it's NATO it's all the
same thing and if they use depleted
uranium cores or something like or
uranium cores in general he will
consider that nuclear war so uh China
Russia how close are we you think well I
think I do think it's funny that um that
every once in a while if I if I tweet
something about hey you should have
emergency food or you know you should be
preparing or you should have a good
pillow to sleep on every night
um when you're when you're in with that
post-apocalyptic World buildings are
falling apart you're gonna wish you had
a good pillow you're gonna wish that how
could you keep how could you stay awake
and I and keep in mind that just a
couple of days ago a couple of days ago
Mike Lindell
prepared for this that out of nowhere
Mike Lindell has been working on a
secret project to design and just
dropped my pillow too is that why they
floated the balloon they're trying to
figure out what he's they're trying
they're trying to they don't want it to
just get to Montana they want to get to
Minnesota right it's because they're
trying to get the secret technology
Illinois is clearly involved this is why
that when she got kicked off the Chinese
are responding to her being kicked off
because she was supposed to be working
in with the pillow conspiracy working in
conjunction with the reverse vampires
that they wanted to steal the technology
from my pillow too that's the problem we
can't allow this Xi Jinping is sitting
in an office room with like all of his
command you know commanders and Generals
and they've got a bunch of my pillows
and he's like how how and he slams the
table
my pillow
but no no go back to your point you're
saying when you tell people to get
emergency food and take the stuff
seriously all right actually take it
seriously and then they call you crazy
they call you Tim foil and then you turn
on the news and and Putin's talking
about nuke in the United States and and
Brussels and London and everything else
uh China's got spy balloons over Montana
over nuclear arsenals where we scrambled
F-22 our most advanced uh fifth
generation fighter but but you're crazy
for wanting some you know a little bit
of extra food supply for your family to
have in the garage I was warning
everybody
you gotta buy chickens that's right you
gotta get you and now
it's funny so we normally have like 180
eggs just stacked on the counters
because we're getting like 30 per day
and then when the egg shortage hit one
day I come into the office the building
in the studio and I look in the kitchen
and they're all gone like I'm constantly
telling the people who work here like
guys take some bags with you because we
have we have too many you got to eat
them and like some are getting like two
weeks old
now I don't need to say anything
actually hit and people took those I
think they're coincided with Luke
Rutkowski leaving the office
didn't they say it was something to do
with the chicken feed no it was that
food
or something I've also heard Purina
people were like don't buy pure I don't
wanna I don't know if Purina is doing
anything right or wrong oh yeah there
was something about chicken for you
right no there was something about like
there was a chicken feed and it was like
a central issue and then that hurt a lot
of chickens and then they went down
which led to supply chains guys are
great think think about how bad our our
country is at this point when we're
living through the collapse of complex
systems every day and we we fail that
just basic maintenance of our supply
chains and pretty much everything where
we can't even do eggs anymore this can't
even handle eggs people watch so I just
finished watching 1883. have you seen it
I haven't seen it but and it's funny
because I know my wife is watching and
sweetheart you're the reason that we
haven't watched it yet but uh
but just seeing people who are right so
but I'm not gonna I'm not gonna I had to
introduce her to Chevy Chase first it's
it's like a year and a half two years
old already but I'm not gonna spoil
anything because some people may not
have seen it but there's just many
things that happen where you're like man
I can't believe they couldn't deal with
that problem it's like I'll give you an
example it's like oh I stubbed my toe is
it bleeding guess I'll die nowadays it's
like we have a ton of things you can do
we're not worried about infection we
wash it with soap usually fine you can
then maybe put antiseptic on it usually
fine like did they not they didn't even
put Whiskey on their wounds I guess they
did did they like some people did and
some people didn't I mean it wasn't
Universal knowledge like I'm listening
to this podcast well this is the Civil
War yeah right what issue I like some
whiskey on the wound he's good right it
sounds like a joke but like it would
actually work uh I'm listening to this
podcast about the Kennedy family and
just like about the children the race
whatever and they had one daughter who
was like severely mentally handicapped
the bottom is her and the podcasters
were Rosemary or Rosemary Eunice was is
super into this right now she's the one
who like cared for her and eventually
started the Special Olympics but the
podcast hosts these two girls who are
doing it were saying like
it seems obvious to us that we're like
don't let her get the lobotomy but at
the time fewer than 100 people had gone
through the surgery there's a chance it
was cutting edge they said it worked so
well and it's this crazy gamble which
did not work made her much worse was was
terrible in the end but like this is
this whole it's easier for us to look
back on 1883 or or these time periods
where it was all experimental they
didn't know how they're going to why
they just needed to see I always think
about you know what is it what are
people going to say about the 2020s you
know 50 years from now 100 years from
now what are they going to go back and
say oh my gosh these these people kept
radioactive microwave ovens in their
homes they put food in them you know or
or self whatever it is yeah that they
look better you could have lived to be
200 years old here's this here's a scary
thing so watch watch 1883 watch The Last
of Us and there's a scene in The Last of
Us that is also very good where they're
Ellie and Joel are walking down the
street and then she's like they see a
crashed plane and she's like did you
used to ride in those and he's like yeah
and she goes wow that's so cool you got
to go in the sky and just and seem like
it at the time and that's that's that's
the main point with all this stuff this
threat of War people need to realize
what makes it possible for us to if I
got two monitors right in front of me we
have TV up on the wall I have no I could
never make one of these days in my
entire life if someone came to me and
said I will give you a billion dollars
make a TV I'd be like
I guess I buy glass and plastic I don't
metal how I'm not gonna be able to make
this it's crazy you need all of the
people and all the different Specialties
so as infrastructure starts collapsing
or if War really does kick off there's
going to be little things that you once
thought were so were so stupid and
mundane you're gonna be begging for and
that's why I've often said when we're
talking about this or Civil War
otherwise think about something that's
extremely common and useful in your
house but also extremely difficult to
synthesize what do you think that is and
then buy it I was thinking is it maybe
mouthwash how hard is it to make it it's
not really that hard to make alcohol so
maybe not but I'm thinking like I don't
know anybody I know people who could
probably make alcohol you know like
whiskey or something you could figure it
out but like a harsher antiseptic like
you know what we have with uh with
mouthwash although whiskey probably
works but what do you what do you guys
think that is like so I'm doubling down
on soap I think so soap actually is
relatively easy to make yeah just upon a
five Smiles what's that just use
saponify oils hence the word so sip on a
fire oils saponify oils oh okay
um what if you have children milk
oh food I mean that was the thing with
the baby uh formula shortage right like
also made this point where it was
critical people didn't understand that
babies can't just eat stuff well this is
where you got this maybe a nice big
steak and I don't know since I threw
Tanya on the under the bus a second ago
I'll I'll do a favor because she was
tweeting about that story where
um these these or this mother was trying
to you know brought her her baby into an
ER I figured exactly where it was and
the baby was completely malnourished she
said I don't understand I feed her milk
every day but it was almond milk and it
was almond milk and she said well yeah
because we're vegan since we're trying
to raise the baby vegan and and they
were like this Baby's it is in danger of
dying it's it's severely malnourished
you can't just make up these decisions I
mean there's a very specific set of
nutrients that especially uh young
children need yeah and especially with
that argument like if you're a vegan and
you're saying oh giving my kids cow's
milk is disrupting the cow's natural
system like you're not stopping the
cow's baby from drinking with milk why
would you stop your baby from drinking
milk you specifically produce for it
like it's it's illogical but it's just
so ideological in this this idea that
well we're vegan so nothing produced by
animals vitamins doesn't make any sense
where do you get your vitamin C
we get it from China yeah no joke that's
crazy you'd have to so I ordered Pirates
I think we ordered a bunch of buckets of
power vitamin C yeah they make it from
black mold wow that's really weird
yeah carrots you think so you said
carrots
um you'd need I mean if you guys have it
I actually live uh rose hips yeah I do
live on a on on a lake so we've got you
know we've got fish
you know we can fish have vitamin C in
it uh no but the official yeah so you
know you can at least and they've got a
vitamin B12 they've got a bunch of stuff
in there this is the crazy thing to me
watching 1883 they're like well we got
beef so we got we got food and I'm like
you just live off of beef fur that's it
you like what you don't need anything
like that's it that's crazy and they
think they have like small amounts of
like stuff that they had like preserved
beforehand right like for me I can't say
what substance I would like want to know
how to make but I just generally would
like to get better at like jarring
things or preserving food right because
if you can grow all kinds of fresh fruit
food that's great but if you can't make
it last the winter then come any kind of
Apocalypse you're done but keep in mind
Tim that that our society today as it
currently stands is the aberration what
we're talking about is the last 10 000
years of human history was exactly that
uh it was where are the plentiful
forests where I can go and Hunt game and
then obviously agriculture comes along
and and okay we're gonna we're gonna
have towns we're gonna have Society
we're gonna have civilization but when
you break when Society breaks down the
question is since we've become so
accustomed to living this type of life
that we have which is extremely
luxurious that we don't have the ability
to just just fend for ourselves
basically and I think with Last of Us
that's a great example you know you
mentioned that thing about the the plane
uh they see a plane crash right
and I I think about it when a couple
years ago I took my kids to Cape
Canaveral and I remember they have the
one of the last space shuttles I think
it's the Atlantis they have in the
warehouse there that you know it's in
the museum but you can go see it and I
remember thinking you know when I was a
kid we had spaceships and and we had
this thought particularly in the 90s
prior to 9 11 that it was going to be
spaceships and then the next thing was
going to be colonies and then we were
just going to keep pushing out for a
lunar Colony first and then Mars was
going to be next and we were just going
to keep going and this was our destiny
right this was this is the way we're
going to work on things now and that
somewhere along the line 9 11 happens we
decided to invade the Middle East then
we decided to debate more of them at
least that wasn't involved in 911 then
further countries that had nothing to do
with the Middle East now we're in
Eurasia because we've always been at war
with Eurasia and we don't seem to have
ever gotten back to that basic idea of
human progress did you watch that video
that went viral recently on Twitter
where it's a high school workout in 1962
and all the young men are yeah like
basically in boot camp yeah they're
they're doing men they're they're
swinging from those bars on what they're
called like they're they're holding
their own body weight monkey bars it's
not monkey bars they're they're they're
they're they're vertical yeah they're
vertical wow Ian wow I really dropped
the ball on that one really just but man
you can stream man yeah we we open polls
I I don't I don't I don't know what
happened to this country but I kind of
feel like the night is always darkest
before the dawn and so as long as you
are working on being selfless
[Music]
the note is always darkest before it
becomes orange before I mean that's
that's actually a really interesting
thing you just mentioned the dawn is
orange and so is the done that's right
and the night is always darkest for the
Don he comes back I'm just saying
whatever happens if you're
self-sufficient if you get out of the
Cities if you get some chickens and
maybe a couple goats or something you
will you'll be okay if you keep your
chicken Safe Keep Your Chickens safe
that's a big thing bro I'm telling you
it's gonna you like if if it really does
hit the fan and War breaks out I'm not
talking about infrastructure collapse
societal collapse I'm talking about the
US government saying we all have to
pitch into the war effort so we're
taking all of the copper we're taking
all this steel the the eggs are being
shipped off to the Troops so you're not
gonna have eggs you're gonna be eating
rice and beans if you're like red bread
they'll love this yeah they're gonna say
eat the bread eat corn they're gonna say
eat this victory garden and then what's
gonna happen is remember you're gonna be
you're gonna be sitting in your in your
in your living room and then also you're
gonna you're gonna hear
and you're gonna go what what you're
gonna run out and you're gonna go ma
something's getting the chickens and
it's gonna be a guy in a flannel shirt
with it with a handlebar mustache and
suspenders running while uh Peter and
John is playing and he's like I'm just
so hungry and you're gonna be like drop
my chicken it's gonna be and then
there's gonna be a bunch of other
hipsters running around with him yeah I
was gonna say it's the hipsters from the
city who are like these people are crazy
I don't need to leave my lifestyle I can
stay in my one bedroom apartment no
chickens for me they're gonna steal your
chicken try and eat it I saw a tweet
from Dash dobrovsky who I actually want
to like a lot I don't know him but it
said that's a work right that guy's not
serious I can't tell he is
instead he's literally an actor like a
child actor yeah he's been on a bunch of
TV shows he was uh he his first
appearance I think was on Jay Leno so
his whole thing's a bit he might be
doing a character but he was a little
over the top for me but I I appreciate
his tweets I really like his tweets
usually I find it entertaining but the
Tweet today was or from yesterday men
who use guns aren't real men what the
hell is he talking about he's talking
about Ukraine he's basically saying that
he hates Ukraine and that anyone in
Ukraine is not a real man because they
shouldn't have guns they should be
surrendering to Russia it's it's maybe
it's a joke maybe it's hyperbolic
they're the force of their testosterone
would be able to to stop the Russian
artists like you you fight with your
hands yeah it's because he's not a real
personality he has he's uh so Nuance bro
actually did a big takedown on him
showing his IMDb track record like the
movies the TV shows he's been in the
things he's filmed it's a bit he's he's
he's a he's a cloud chaser I see I
wouldn't be surprised if he really
doesn't truly believe everything he says
it's kind of a short-sighted state does
that mean Alec Baldwin isn't a real man
let me let me let me give a special
shout out again I'm gonna give it a
special shout out to to Hassan and his
fans because when uh I I did a video
saying that Hassan was correct
about the cataract surgeries that's
interesting yeah he was like this fills
me of the rage that we just don't give
these people these things and I was like
yeah I agree it's like we're spending
all this money on war and stuff I think
he missed something though when when I
said we spent 100 billion dollars on
Ukraine right Hassan's response was to
start laughing and then offer up no
critique as to why what I said was wrong
and as fans all started calling me
stupid and they said before that I was
right but as soon as I said don't
support Ukraine with our money all of a
sudden I'm wrong these people are I call
them neocons you know it's like neocon
but communist yeah I think there's a
Comics
they want they're Communists but they
want foreign intervention and War but
you know what it so they're basically
like John Bolton and then Sean
probably get along really well I don't
think Hassan would want to solve the
Ukraine I don't think he wants War I
think he was pissed because you he
thinks that what you're doing is is
deferring to
um conservative agit prop as he refers
to it as like yeah the the blindness
thing is ridiculous that we're not
helping blind people but then when you
mention Ukraine he's like why are you
talking about conservative news
conservativeness just Ukraine in his
mind it's like a conservative he
literally says In that clip the
military-industrial complex is the
problem and we shouldn't be giving them
our money and that's literally what I
said a hundred billion dollars going
into Foreign Wars and countries that are
not on our border I think it was gender
Pakistani gender stuff
the starter pack of I'm I'm edgy but
it's okay to tweet these things and then
he agreed with me and says they're doing
that gender studies thing as a liberal
PR so he basically agrees with my points
but then rallies his followers to attack
because it's not real commentary real
commentary is when Hassan says I I'm
filled with rage Watson watching this Mr
Beast thing and then I say I see a lot
of people criticizing Hassan but I agree
with him that we're spending 100 billion
dollars over Season War that we spent 10
million on gender studies in Pakistan
when a single dollar of that could have
gone towards Medical Care in this
country he then agrees with those points
because he has to but then insults me
derides me and then rallies his
followers against me you start insulting
me because it's not real commentary real
commentary would be assessing the
political position
analyzing it and then either agreeing or
disagreeing and making making your
statement not just going
he thinks we should be at war in Ukraine
but anyway that's my point about
desperate dubrowsky and I want to go off
on but I do I do have an interesting
similar take to Hassan but I I think in
it it's it's more in line with what
you're saying that it's not just Ukraine
though because what you're dealing with
and I think what a lot of people are
dealing with with the response to Mr
Beast was cognitive uh dissonance was it
a classic textbook case of cognitive
dissonance because here comes a guy who
just fronts the money for this surgery
and is able to cure a thousand people's
blindness in seemingly overnight in an
instant whereas it costs about six
thousand dollars per surgery and think
about what we've been doing as a country
for the last three years it's been
crisis after crisis after crisis where
the media your favorite influencers your
uh your government officials are telling
you that you must care about the current
thing the current thing is the most
important thing in the world uh the
going thing they used to call it in the
UK that this must be dealt with and it
doesn't matter how much it cost whether
it be diversity and systemic racism
whether it be uh covid and we must we
must defeat covert we must have the
vaccine mandates it has to be this it
has to be done did anyone against us is
uh is is part of the problem and and of
course remember Biden given speeches
about this and now that that thing is
we're in Eurasia we've always been at
war in Eurasia it must be this and
suddenly so so there's that Moment of
clarity where it's like the Principal
Skinner meme right of am I out of touch
and then immediately it comes right back
that no it must be the children who are
wrong that's cognitive dissonance thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time